now with those temperatures moving on
into the neighborhoods we dipped into
the upper 60s up in aleonte also in
summerlin
live local and now 76 trombones along
the strip and in henderson
there's a better chance for some
lingering showers up in lincoln county
more so in southwestern utah good
morning cedar city with 52 good
afternoon and good morning to kingman
with a 73
hanging on close to the mid 80s over in
death valley so the weather headlines
yes the haze and the smoke are back
highs under 100 lows at least in the 70s
although some neighborhoods as we just
saw are in the 60s only 95 for the high
today after 99 yesterday well below
normal in both cases so the air quality
is in the unhealthy for sensitive groups
category a finger of smoke from
california wildfires obviously much
worse over california this first band
will roll through but by tomorrow night
there may be more threatening haze for
your weekend
storms over the northern rockies what's
left of what was tropical depression
fred leaving some storms up in the new
england states hurricane grace just now
coming ashore over the yucatan peninsula
but wait there's more tropical storm
henri could become a hurricane and
affect new england over the weekend all
right your eight day forecast only the
mid-90s for the next few days inching up
closer to triple digits over the weekend
but uh john and hector the main thing
we're watching for today is that smoky
haze and unhealthy air